do you think I want to be here do you
think I want to be here I don't know
what you want you've given me one word
answer since I got here so if I get you
a towel you'll stop following me to my
car yes
fine but I'm only doing this because you
called me rude and I take that as a
compliment
that is actor Emily Hampshire and the
popular show schitt's Creek she played
the snarky and hilarious hilarious TV
Bud everybody loves Stevie now she is an
author her debut graphic novel is called
Amelia Airwood basic witch I love the
title The Story follows Amelia who is
the black sheep of a famous family of
witches Amelia often gets herself in
magical trouble and now her family is
about to star in their own reality TV
show the book is distributed by Simon
Schuster which is part of the same
company as CBS Emily Hampshire great to
see you good morning good morning I
still can't get over this instead in the
background this is the most amazing
thing that's ever happened all we did is
say you're a beautiful book and put it
on the wall right our director our game
almazar is the graphics guy who does all
this but let's talk about this book um
you say so I probably gave it away in
the intro there but you say this was
inspired by the Kardashians well I I
mean well I was watching the Kardashians
as one does right
um and I was looking at this show
thinking like this is a a real family
like they're really sisters and what if
I just happened to be born into this
family I would be the worst Kardashian
ever like I would get kicked off the
show I would get trapped in the waist
trainer like pizza on my face ruin
makeup worst Kardashian so that's how
this kind of came about I um Amelia is
from this famous family of super witches
um and they have their own reality show
and they kick her off well they don't
even kick her off they cut her out of
the show because her magic is just not
on brand she's bad at Magic she's a
basic witch
was there pulling from your past in some
ways to get some of this
um she's not not me
I definitely there's a a lot of me in
this book I.E it begins with a jello
pool
um I've been dreaming of a jello pool
ever since I saw it jiggle I have always
wanted that
um and she's also she she all her
sisters are adopted and Amelia is the
only biological child and my brother is
adopted and he is so much like my
parents he is like the best doesn't he
they love him and I am I'm an accident
like or a miracle baby
um but I'm so different from them like
I'm the black sheep so I found that
interesting to have all the the
um the that the biological child doesn't
have this magical thing where she's
supposed to it feels like by the way you
should be able to make that jello pool
happen well you would think right I
would think I could put it in movies and
stuff but a jello pool first of all
health and safety wouldn't I'd have to
sanitize this yellow or in life we did
it and we did it in a sorority thing
there's a whole Jello job anybody who's
a pie fine knows the pie Phi Jello jump
I'll talk to you okay okay you've got it
wow yeah I'm serious okay uh the other
thing that's critical about this is like
speaking of your past there are uh I
think the term is Easter eggs that the
illustrators have put little like things
from your acting career that are here
some of your favorites what are they
I mean there's a Larry air in there
there's also so I I love musicals
um the only I just don't like the
Phantom and so the artist Kristen
gutsnook put a box set of all the
musicals except for the phantom
um there's also I did a show called 12
Monkeys and
um there's the virus from 12 Monkeys
somewhere amongst the panels I just
found out from one of your producers
that there she told me about an Easter
egg in here that I hadn't even found
like I'm still finding stuff in the
panels so so go ahead
no because Emily you know you you talk
about being the black sheep um you and I
have communicated about how sometimes
it's difficult when you are talking to
your parents about who you are and
you've talked about how this book can
also serve as a road map for younger
children to find themselves what would
you say to your younger self as you were
trying to navigate your life to the
point of where you are now oh my God I
love that you asked that because I feel
like the process of making this book
gave me the opportunity to go back and
tell my my younger self like everything
you think that's wrong with you that is
your problem or that you're trying to
fix or hide that's your magic like
that's the thing that makes you special
and when you're older that's going to be
the thing that is like your thing
um so that's that's what I feel like I
get from the book when I read it
um I feel more inspired to be my
authentic self and hopefully other
people feel that way that's beautiful I
have to say this real quick I'm sorry
shit's creek everybody wants to see a
reunion something something another
happened come on break it right here
people say this to me or they were
really upset when it ended and I'm like
I didn't I don't have a job anymore I
lost all my friends it was harder on me
but I don't I don't believe that we
wouldn't have something else again we're
not going to do the series again but we
like each other too much I love it we
love you and this thank you so much
Amelia earhood basic Witch is on sale
right now pick it up
won't be disappointed we'll be right
back
[Music]